.
ERNIE JOHNSON, SHAQUILLE O'NEAL,
KENNY "THE JET" SMITH, CHARLES
BARKLEY.
>> CAN I VENT?
>> YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO UNLOAD?
>> CAMERA FOUR.
>> YOU YOU KNOW, I THINK MOST
REPORTERS ARE COWARDS, THE FIRST
MONTH OF THE SEASON, YOU BLAMED
EVERYTHING ON RUSSELL WESTBROOK
FOR THE LAKERS BID, AND YOU
BLAME WESTBROOK, NOW I HEAR YOU
GOING TO FIRE FRANK VOGEL.
RUSS IS LEARNING, FRANK VOGEL IS
A TERRIFIC COACH.
IT AIN'T RIGHT AND IT AIN'T
COOL.
DAVIS, YOU BETTER PLAY BETTER.
I SAID IF THE LAKERS ARE GOING
TO BE GOOD, IT'S GOING TO BE ON
YOU.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
RUSSELL.
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH LeBRON.
YOU DONE CROSSED THE LINE.
BECAUSE I REALLY LIKE FRANK
VOGEL.
IT AIN'T HIS FAULT.
LISTEN, I BLAME ANTHONY DAVIS.
YOU KNOW I LIKE YOU AS A PERSON.
BUT YOU AIN'T DOING WHAT YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE.
YOU'RE IN YOUR PRIME.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE ONE OF THE
FIVE BEST PLAYERS IN THE WORLD
AND YOU AIN'T HOLDING UP YOUR
END OF THE BARGAIN.
AND NOW YOU'RE GOING TO FIRE --
THAT IS TOTAL BS, MAN, AND NOW I
FEEL BETTER.
>> THAT IS WHY WE'RE HERE, TO
MAKE YOU FEEL BETTER.
>> IT DIDN'T HAPPEN YET.
IT SHOULDN'T BE DISCUSSED.
>> WHO IS DISCUSSING IT?
>> HE'S CATCHING SOME HEAT.
CATCHING SOME HEAT.
>> YEAH, BUT --
>> REALITY --
>> I'M WITH YOU.
>> WHAT'S REALITY?
>> THAT'S REALITY.
>> NO, NO --
>> KENNY.
>> YOU KNOW HOW I KNOW WHEN
YOU'RE GOING TO GET FIRED IN
WHEN THEY START TO ASK YOU IF
YOU'RE GETTING FIRED.
>> WE HAVE A DISCUSSION.
SHUT BEHIND BE AN THE PLAYERS.
AND CHUCK, HE AIN'T HOLDING UP
TO HIS BARGAIN.
IF YOU'RE SHOOTING THAT BAD FROM
THE FREE-THROW LINE, THAT IS
TELLING ME ONE THING, GET YOUR
ASS IN THE POST.
>> I WOULD SAY --
>> 52% FROM -- 52% FROM THE
FIELD.
19% FROM THREE.
FOR ANTHONY DAVIS.
>> YEAH, BUT THE OTHER THING --
NO, THE OTHER THING THAT THE
LAKERS, YOU KNOW, THEIR FANS AND
THE PEOPLE THAT FOLLOW THE
LAKERS, THEY HAVE DELUSIONS OF
GRANDEUR.
FIRST, LeBRON JAMES HASN'T BEEN
THERE MOST OF THE SEASON.
>> DON'T DO IT.
>> NO, I'M JUST SAYING, WHEN
GIANNIS, JRUE HOLIDAY, THE BUCKS
STRUGGLED.
>> HE HANDLING THE BALL TOO.
>> SHOULD ANTHONY DAVIS BE ONE